welcome back to las vegas now founders
coffee wants to help you step your
breakfast game up in 2022 okay britney
risquez is back with their brand new
menu items whether you're looking for
something sweet savory big small you got
it all yeah we do we have a new
breakfast burrito which is amazing has
chorizo
eggs we have a strawberries new nutella
toast for all those sweet moments and if
you want something that's good for lunch
you definitely have our turkey club on
multigrain it's really good and there's
a drive-through there's a drive-through
who doesn't want to drive through you
can't ask for much more than that okay
let's get to i know we have something
special going on today we're we're
throwing down we are and you know what i
make these so much throughout my day i'm
going to be blindfolded
you have an advantage okay so okay good
so what are we making we are gonna make
our blueberries and cream toast it's
amazing it has blueberries honey cream
cheese coconut honey it's an amazing
snack without being too sweet okay you
ready so put your blindfold on all right
let's see how we do okay is there is
there a special technique that you can
you know give me before we start don't
be blindfolded
that's a good point all right now i
don't know how i'll do and i'm not
blindfolded so that i don't know how
that makes me look are you ready okay
three
two one okay okay and i'm just guessing
what goes first here just i have a video
i feel like
i feel like uh
yo
you are making a mess but i guess you
know what it's okay i just need honey
um what do you think rocky is that
something that you would eat yeah
absolutely okay and then what i love
about it is that it's simple it's you
know am i oh it's hard
i definitely feel it in my hands you are
doing terribly oh
it's okay you know what
it's okay it's okay i got this you know
what
do you guys have fun making this back in
the kitchen because
it's like an art project you know it is
you know i feel like i feel blueberries
on here let's give it a taste
no it's dry girl girlfriend all your
blueberries just fell off honey it's
okay though
got one more step okay
okay i'm ready
i can take your blindfold off
how do i do
amazing
amazing ah there we go and obviously
this is something great you can make at
home with your kids but absolutely why
not go to founders and just get it done
yourself not blindfolded not blindfolded
right okay so tell people where you guys
are located and what else is on the menu
i know you have a full coffee menu and
everything so we are located um right
next to the
costco on saint rose and then we're also
located across the street from the ikea
on durango we have so many new things
guys every month we donate and create
something different for a charity and
one thing we do have different types of
egg bites we have vegetarian vegan
options something for everybody at
founders coffee i love it it's one of my
favorites well thank you this is
delicious isn't it it is
jason's number to you
pretty you did a great job